we've expanded the rights to bear arms
to carry to possess and people need to
understand that you go back before 2008
it was still very difficult so Victory
upon Victory the move made by this
governor was the was a death throw it
was pure desperation and even after she
did it a bunch of dudes showed up in
Albuquerque and were like nah and they
showed up armed they're losing they know
they're losing and here's the best part
about it it forced people like David
Hogg and Ted Lou to come out and be
alike we actually oppose the the Banning
of Guns by decree here's the best part
beyond that
when they started shutting everything
down over kovid saying that public
health trumped the Constitution this has
forced them backwards and now you've got
personalities like David Hogg saying
there is no Public Health exception to
the Constitution so we've forced their
position back past the Line This is
Victory